and the Dutchess of Sussex has suffered
a setback in her case against associated
newspapers as a parent company of the
Mail Online and Mail on Sunday after a
judge ruled that part of her case should
be struck out where we can get more
detail on this now joining me from the
firm killing she is the international
media lawyer Paul tweed afternoon to you
Paul now this was a preliminary ruling
wasn't it in in this fairly wide-ranging
case just just talk us through at what
it means a good afternoon and yes and
this would not be an uncommon situation
in media litigation what happens is both
sides have to put case in writing in the
form of a court pleading and then the
case of the Duchess's lawyers and in
their particulars of clear man in the
arguments they were putting forward on
her behalf and they included various
allegations that associated newspapers
have been acting dishonestly and that
they had been deliberately trying to
stir up a conflict between Megan and her
father and this aspect of their
complaint and this is only part of the
Duchess's claim of course I mean her
primary complaint is a claim based on
misuse of private information breach of
our data and copyright infringement but
this particular aspect was the focus of
a susheela's preliminary attack and
there was a new hearing some several
days it several weeks ago and the judge
now has given his ruling that this
aspect of the claim of Lee Megan's clear
should be struck out so its first blood
to associated and this will narrow the
battleground albeit the case is still a
long way to go there are still that the
broader the core legal issues to be
determined but this will be a
significant factor in terms of the
witnesses that may be required or called
above both parties and from associated
point of view you know it is said
you know quite a strong message from the
outset that you know if they've got it
wrong if there is a breach of the law
and if there's been their miss your
private information misuse of Megan's
data well then that will be a separate
legal issue it's a can continue to fight
but that they were not motivated by bad
faith or dishonesty and I think this is
an important ruling for them yeah I was
just gonna ask you to further clarify
there you were sort of hinting at it
saying it's gonna narrow the focus of
the case and might change the witnesses
that can be called etc don'ts the fact
that that as associated has been
successful here does that strengthen
their hands for the rest of the case
it's certainly the core fundamental
issues are still had to be tried and
they are still very much open here and
they're not seem that this fundamental
factor there was a personal letter and
that personal letter has been published
by assembly newspaper and there are a
number of the fundamental issues that
will need to be heard and determined by
the court not least as to whether it was
in the public interest for this personal
method to be published or whether it was
something that the public would simply
be interested in which is a completely
different scenario and the court we're
going to have to determine this very
important issue a very fundamental issue
Hathi substantive hearing of the case